どうも、
青鬼デス。ウソです。はじめしゃちょーです
青鬼になってみました
今回なんですけども
なんと、青鬼３がリリースされました
おめでとうございます
ＰＣゲームとして大人気の
「青鬼」ついに３が↑リリースされました。
今回は何と無人島がテーマということで
青鬼史上最大のスケールとなっているみたいです
ぜひ皆さん遊んでみてね
青鬼３がリリースされたということで
肩かゆい
青鬼３リリース記念ということで
私今、家の中に、大量の青鬼を
捕獲しておりますというわけで今日は
仕掛けてみようと思います
青鬼と生き物は人を見つけると、ずっと追いかけ回す
というわけで青鬼を忠実に再現し、
ターゲットを見つけたらずっと追いかけると言う
システムになっております
もうすぐターゲットが来るので
やべ、おれメイク落とさなきゃ！メイク落とさなきゃ！
やばい！メイクの時間がやばい！
ちょとまて、早く！メイクを落としてきます！では！
やべぇな顔
ｽﾘｽﾘ
ｶﾞﾀ、ｶﾞﾀﾝ！ｶﾞﾀｶﾞﾀ、ｶﾝ！
青鬼）ﾌｯwww
はじめ ）もうすぐ来ます（小声）
(はじめが階段を登る音)
(はじめとターゲットが階段を降りる音)
ターゲット）何もない？
はじめ）何も無いんじゃない？
青鬼の音楽♪
まさき）行くんじゃないの！？！？
まさき）いくんじゃないの！？！？
まさき）ねぇ！行くんじゃないの！？！？
まさき）行くんじゃなかったのぉ！？
まさき）やだよぉ(T_T)
まさき）あーっはっは/////
はじめ）大丈夫か！？まさき！
まさき）なになに！？